[Music]
well thank you everyone for coming
we're soap well on behalf of Rick
MacArthur Harper's Magazine and book
culture we're so pleased to be here to
celebrate born on third base a
one-percenter makes the case for
tackling inequality bringing home what
or bringing wealth home and committing
to the common good and so that author is
Chuck Collins and again we're so happy
to have him here for our talk Harper's
Magazine has a vested interest in
keeping a important written word in
circulation and one of those ways is
here at book culture so we do encourage
you to pick up a copy or two or three of
tonight's book in order to keep this a
community space I think Rick McArthur
who's one of the part owners to space as
well famously has said that he was
really terrified that when the space
became available to become a bank branch
and so we're really glad that it's a
bookstore and we hope that you'll
celebrate that too
some of you may remember this space as
the Endicott booksellers that was 20
years ago and book culture has been here
almost two years so again so we're so
happy to be here in order to host chuck
collins he's a researcher campaigner
storyteller and writer based at the
Institute for Policy Studies where he co
edits inequality org he has written
extensively on wealth inequality in
previous books like 99 to 1 wealth and
our common wealth with Bill Gates senior
and economic apartheid in America and as
well as for the nation the American
Prospect and numerous other magazines
and news outlets Collins grew up in the
1% and as the great-grandson of meat
packer Oscar Mayer mayor but I use 26 he
gave away his inheritance
and he's been working to reduce
inequality and strengthen communities
since 1982 and in the process he
co-founded numerous initiatives
including both for the common good now
merge with patriotic millionaires United
for a fair economy and divest invest so
again thank you everybody for coming and
I'm going to go ahead and turn over to
Jack thanks it'll lead me to use that
right okay
Thank You Cody and thank you for coming
out on this evening and I want to this
is the first event that I'm doing the
book actually is published tomorrow
formally so thank you for coming out to
to an unpublished book event and I want
to also just recognize Morris pearl who
wrote the foreword to this book he's the
chairman of the patriotic millionaires
which is we can tell you more about that
Network but he was the former managing
director of Blackrock and you may have
seen his op-ed in the New York Times
today on transparency and corporate
taxation so we're thrilled that I'm
thrilled that Morris was able to do the
forward and he could autograph the book
as well later it might be worth more
than mine so it was anyway
so as Cody said I this is the book is
called born on third base which actually
comes from a quote from the coach of the
Dallas Cowboys Barry Switzer who said
some people were born on third base and
thought they hit a triple and I am one
of the people who was born on third base
I as Kody said I'm the great-grandson of
the meat packer Oscar Mayer my father
used to say bringing home the bacon has
a different meaning in our family and I
grew up in a affluent suburb of Detroit
actually thought that I was middle class
I have a couple my classmates here and
they would remember that there were you
know the daughter of Lee Iacocca and you
know the Taubman family and people who
showed up to college the high school and
chauffeur driven cars whereas my dad
took me in his own mercedes-benz
you know so I knew that I was not in
that top echelon
but the cot the high school that I went
to Cranbrook school is also the school
that Mitt Romney went to and our school
motto is aim high which is depicted by
an archer shooting an arrow straight up
into the air which if you think about it
it's not something you would let your
children do right but I want it I've
written a couple of books on issues of
inequality but what I'm trying to do
with born on third bases tell more
stories talk about how we think about
inequality and the myths about why we
have inequality and try to disrupt some
of those myths and narratives that that
allow these inequalities to perpetuate
and I want to start with just a short
story but it's my own story which is
when I was 26 so 30 years ago my first
job out of college was I worked with
tenants who lived in mobile home parks
to help them buy their parks as
cooperatives and so I'm sitting in a
double-wide mobile home in Barnard in
Massachusetts and there are nine of the
resident leaders in this thirty unit
park sitting there and I am actually the
consultant that's helping them to figure
out how to buy it and they are at risk
their park is up for sale they need to
see if they can pull the money together
to be able to buy the park so there's a
lot at stake and I'm sitting there and
one thing you should know is that age 26
I had excruciating skin acne I and I
look much younger than I actually was so
these resident leaders are looking me
somebody you know somebody looks like
they're 19 with bad skin who are
supposedly going to be the person who's
going to help them buy this part and I
am honestly in agony for two reasons one
because I'm I've actually done all of
their financials I've privately
interview
each of them about what they could
afford to pay toward the new park and
how much they could pay toward rent and
I know like more private information I
know all their financial secrets in a
way and I have figured out that they
don't have enough money like a third of
the people have like no savings and a
third of the people have you over there
you know our retirees with very modest
amounts of savings and so I have to
break the news to them that they
actually there's not enough money to
even get toward the down payment we need
to raise we're about $35,000 short the
other reason I'm in agony is I was born
on third base
I actually a few years before that had
received some wealth from my family and
I knew that I could actually write a
check for that $35,000 and close the gap
and I'm actually thinking that I might
do that because I've actually done this
analysis or where I realized I
personally have five or six times more
money than all the 30 people in this
park combined and somehow that did not
bounce out in my moral universe so so
I'm sitting there and I break the news
to the residents I basically explained
we have this gap and there's a little
bit of a pall in the room and then one
of the men says this guy Reggie he says
well I have I can pay my share of the
down payment and I can put $5,000 more
into the burches and I'm probably the
only person who knows that reg that
that's all the money he has and then
another another woman mrs. Dunn daughter
says I have six thousand dollars that
I'll put in and I realize like she's
putting her whole savings in and Harlan
and Mary Parra whose home were sitting
in is they say well we can afford are we
you know he had a good job at greenfield
happened I and he had some retirement
savings and he's going to put in there
ten thousand dollars stake and they're
going to buy mrs. Riva
to share on the condition that she
should never know to protect her dignity
and around the room they go and all nine
of these people put every bit of the
money that they have on the table and
they are about four thousand dollars
short five thousand dollars short and
the daughter Harlan Mary's daughter come
in and she says I'll write the check for
the other five thousand and they've done
it they've closed the gap they cheer
they start writing out checks and
handing them to me to take to the bank
to open up our account for the down
payment and I remember driving in that
car thinking to the bank thinking I
almost wrote a check but I didn't have
to because these people were all in and
they survived they succeeded they bought
the park they on the day of the closing
the men showed up with like cigars like
they were proud parents
Harlan told the local paper that we have
been wandering the land but we have just
bought we've just bought the land from
Pharaoh
we are hostage no more and one woman
came up to me Mary Harlan's wife said
you know you're a smart young man you
could get a job on Wall Street you don't
have to be hanging out with a bunch of
fogies like us I said no you know I
can't think of anywhere I'd rather be
actually and then she sort of leaned
quietly to me and said have you ever
tried Noxzema for your skin
and I said no I've tried everything so I
left there and that's when I decided you
know what I'm 26 years old this money I
don't actually need it and other people
need it more and so I made this decision
to give away the wealth and I wrote to
my father and I said this is my plan and
he said he called me up and he said you
haven't given away it have you I said
not yet so let me come out and talk to
you so he actually came out from
Michigan to Boston where I live and he
said you know there's a lot you're young
there's a lot of things that can go
wrong you know there's a lot of
having this money could be a cushion
what if you you know you're single and
you have no children but what if someday
you have a partner and that partner gets
ill wouldn't you want that money to sort
of help help buffer that make that
easier or what if you have a child and
that child has a special need wouldn't
you like to have that money why don't
you not why did you think about all the
things that potentially could go wrong I
said well I have been thinking about
those things and well then I would if I
be in the same boat as 99% of the other
people I know I would have to get some
help
he said well you probably have to fall
back on government I said well yeah well
that's a that's that's not a good thing
so well you know maybe then I'd have a
stake in making sure that that it was
better but the safety net was better so
well that's kind of idealistic but okay
I understand
you should do what you were called to do
so I went to the National Bank of
Detroit I signed the papers to transfer
what was at the time to meet an enormous
amount of money about a half a million
dollars in 1986 which if I just kind of
left it and let it grow it'd be seven or
eight million dollars today so not not a
mega fortune but a substantial amount of
money for me and my trust officer at the
National Bank of Detroit
african-american woman grew up in
poverty in Detroit sort of looked at me
and said are you okay I said you know I
think so she says no mean are you going
to be okay I said I think so because
even and then I didn't really understand
the incredible mountain of privilege
that I had that the money was just part
of it that it was this intergenerational
transfer of and preparation and social
networks and white skin privilege I had
the money was just part of it I didn't
understand that to me at that moment it
felt like a leap of faith so I signed
this wealth over to a number of
foundations including something called
the funding exchange here in New York
and went back to my life
working with mobile home tenants and a
couple months later
something bad did happen my house burned
down the house I was living in and
everything I owned was destroyed and no
one was hurt so it wasn't horrible in
that way but it was disorienting and the
day after I was sifting through and my
friend Greg's we're looking for photos
and mementos anything we could find
after the car the house had been sort of
trashed with all this water and I look
up and here comes three or four cars
pull up and how do the cars climb the
Bernhard Stern mobile home park tenants
and they have trash bags and casseroles
and I think that was the first time I
thought yeah I think I am going to be
okay and I share that story because to
me that reminds me of like the real
wealth which is in the relationships
which is in the connections in the
community and that those folks had
taught me something very very important
about solidarity about being all in for
each other and that is part of the
foundation so for 30 years I've been
working on these issues of the growing
wealth and a wealth gap and I've
coordinated campaigns where I've tried
to organize other people who are in the
1% like Bill Gates and we did a campaign
Polly Cleveland is he or she was part of
that to mobilize a 1,500
multimillionaires and billionaires to
oppose the repeal of the estate tax but
my belief now is there's lots of things
we need to do to sort of build
coalitions and campaigns but part of the
work that we need to do is to change the
stories that we tell ourselves about
inequality and that I more and more
believe it's fundamentally a heart
problem that we have a heart problem
when it comes to understanding the
impact of these inequalities and here's
the moment I think we're in think about
the trajectory that our current society
is on
in terms of inequality yummy you may
have seen news reports there's good news
that the census the median income has
popped up a little bit after many many
years it's still not where you it wasn't
in 2007 it's nowhere near where it was
in 1999 but so but we're living in a
time of extreme inequality overall most
of the income and wealth gains of the
last 30 but really since the economic
meltdown of 2009 have gone to the top
one percent and even within that the top
one-tenth of one percent and assets
wealth if we look at that it's become
more extreme the the Institute for
Policy Studies where I work we do a
number of studies every year and we just
did a study that looked at found that
the Forbes 400 the most the 400
wealthiest billionaires in the society
have more wealth than the bottom sixty
two percent of the population combined a
hundred of these millionaires
billionaires have more wealth in these
higher African American population 20
richest people in the United States who
could sit in a one Gulfstream 650 jet
luxury jet 20 people have as much wealth
as half the population so we have now
entered into a new warp speed of
inequality and if you look at the racial
wealth divided and again I just did a
study on so that the trajectory if we
look if we say if the racial wealth gap
between whites and blacks and Latinos
continues into the same in the same way
at first it would take 200 if if black
wealth continued to grow at the same
level it is today it would take 228
years for blacks to catch up to the
median wealth of whites
if white wealth stood still and that 30
years from now the racial wealth divide
will be twice as big so as the French
economist Thomas Piketty pointed out
we're moving toward becoming a
hereditary aristocracy of wealth and if
you look at the racial dimension of that
it's a white aristocracy of wealth and
so that's the trajectory that we're on
and I just want to read a very brief I'm
not going to read much
but I want to read a little bit from the
introduction of born on third base there
are many reasons we need to rethink our
predicament but for a moment let's
consider this one which in many ways
Trump's them all as a planet we are
experiencing an ecological crisis
climate change and ocean acidification
along with breaches of other planetary
boundaries will alter our food and
energy systems and transform our way of
life there have been recent news
accounts about us billionaires buying
mountain fortresses in the Rockies and
Davos billionaires buying getaway farms
in New Zealand with airplane landing
strips the but these escape fantasies
are delusional thinking the island
paradises will be swamped from rising
sea levels the mountain redoubts will be
choked with smoke of burning forests
it's in no one's interest to continue
operating as if a few privileged people
are going to escape on a spaceship or
retreat to a mountain clay mountaintop
Enclave the point there is the
ecological crisis you know there is no
wealth without natural wealth there is
no wealth in a degraded earth put that
together there is no true society in an
extremely polarized economic apartheid
Society so part of my point in this book
is an infant is to my brothers and
sisters who are in the 1% I want I want
to go out and engage with people who
have wealth not just maybe the 1% but
you know think of ourselves in the
United States as we're at the pinnacle
of global wealth and my message there is
bring the wealth home look at how these
inequalities not only are bad for most
people in the world they're actually bad
for wealthy people there's this kind of
curious alignment of interest here of
course wealthy people are not going to
experience the full brunt of the
ecological crisis and the inequality
crisis at least in the immediate term
but it undermines the quality of life
for everybody and there's now like a
mountain of research showing this you
know you care about public health you
care about your own health you care
about your children's futures these
inequalities will undermine everything
you care about and I could go on about
that but I won't so so the question is
how do we change this and my point of
view is there are campaigns or the paper
you know the patriotic millionaires and
you know there's an the our revolution
the kind of offshoot of the Bernie
Sanders campaign and there's People's
Action um there's work that black lives
matter the movement for black lives of
these movements that are building and
that are engaging people and that are
really the engines of social change but
my point of view is actually people in
the 1% we need you we need us to step up
to fundamentally change this trajectory
which is in no one's interest and so in
this book what I do is I first of all I
I have messages for both my brothers and
sisters and the 1% for where affluent or
wealthy but also some thoughts for
everyone else my message to people in
the who hold most of the wealth and
power in this society is to come home to
bring the wealth out of the shadows out
of the speculative financial markets out
of the fossil fuel industry which is
pushing us to the precipice
psychologically and bring it home
reroute it in local community investing
and impact investing go off the wall
street grid come back into the real
economy of goods and services and
livelihoods so bring the wealth home
bring your self home which is to like
put your full stake in a place and make
a commitment to make sure that everybody
in that place thrives and to use your
all of the social capital and wealth and
investment capital and philanthropic you
know charitable giving to make that
possible
to come home it's also to is to tell the
true stories about the origins of wealth
and here is where I think we have a very
important role which is there's there
are these mythologies about wealth and
success and who better to kind of
disrupt or debunk some of those than
people who actually have seen and had
the experience of growing wealth you
think about here's a narrative than I
write about this in the book the makers
and the takers right 2012 when Mitt
Romney was running for office he did his
own you know campaign donor event faux
pas just like Hillary saying deplorable
he talked about the makers and the
takers you know narrative think how
powerful that is you hear that
everywhere if you read our Lee Hoke
shields new book strangers in their own
land about the Tea Party activists in
Louisiana that makers and takers
understanding the world there are the
makers the virtuous makers who create
wealth who are the engines of the Train
and they're the takers the people who
who take from society and how insidious
that is and how destructive it is and
how it renders people who need help but
also everybody everybody in our society
benefits from the things that we do
together whether it's public investments
or the Commons that we built together
one of the first people I met doing this
work with a guy named Martin Rothenberg
who I tell his story in this book which
is he is a software engineer and I was
involved in this effort to keep the
estate tax from being repealed and at
the time Bill Clinton was the president
Congress had voted to repeal the one and
only tax on inherited wealth and he was
going to veto it and he needed a
businessperson to stand with him so they
called our office
and Martin Rothenberg stood up and
here's what he said he he got up and he
said I grew up in a family with no
wealth in Queens and I my parents never
took a vacation they worked all the time
but I went to a great public school and
I went to a library that was open on the
weekends and there was a librarian there
and she said Martin I have a book for
you she knew he was interested in
technology and education and and she
said here's a biography of Thomas Edison
he said you know I grew up in a
low-income family but but I had great
opportunities somebody else paid for my
school and for my for that library to be
open on the weekends and then he went
into he got a completely free you know
college education and there are some
amazing institutions in this city that
have made that possible for generations
and then he went to into the field of
technology new technology the Internet
which was built largely through taxpayer
investment and he started a company and
this is Martin now at the west wing of
the White House telling his story he
says mr. president you know I sold my
company a couple years ago for thirty
million dollars and are you telling me I
don't have a responsibility to pay back
the society that made it almost entirely
possible for me to have the
opportunities I did said no in fact I
have an obligation so so that some other
child out there who's not born wealthy
can have the same opportunities I had
so Martin's story and a lot of the
stories that I tell in here are of what
I would call people from the 1% or
wealthy people who have come home they
have figured out how to move wealth to
local communities how to rejoin and
connect in that way the other part of
this message though is to everyone else
and I in this book I write about having
been working on issues of inequality for
many many years I have to say I was part
of I would say fomenting attitudes of
class war meaning my theory of change
the theory of change of United for a
fair economy and other groups I was part
of was if you know if we could get
people as focused and rape their rage on
the billionaires and transnational
corporations and focus that anger there
that's how we would build a movement for
social change and I think there are
reasons to obviously be angry and raged
you know every every day we go can open
up the newspaper and read about you know
somebody who you know buys a
prescription drug and increases the
price 5,000% you know so there's some
good reasons to think about bringing out
the pitchforks but my what I had to ask
myself was how is this transformation
really going to happen and you know is
that class rage and shame working and my
you know so my new perspective is it's
understandable that where people feel
angry and rage but there are allies in
the room what mics my life experience
now is there are people in the 1% who
are behind the scenes they're here in
this room tonight they're doing things
behind the scenes they're working for
economic justice and there are many many
more who are waiting to be invited to
something bigger and greater and grander
so my message to everyone else is don't
give up entirely there are there is a
segment of the reachable wealthy the
reachable rich I call it now there are
people who you know think of the Koch
brothers who use their wealth and power
to get more wealth and power but that's
a small segment and on the other side we
have the patriotic millionaires and
groups like that that are sort of out
there organizing to put forward a
different vision but there's this whole
other segment of people who are
uninterested come to fix the future but
my pep talk to them is if you feel
powerless think of how everybody else
feels you know you need to bring your
wealth to the table and welcome so in
this book I actually do a little bit of
sort of coaching or strategizing for all
of us who are working as part of social
movements I have a little section called
the roadmap to riches stand which is to
understand the different segments of the
wealthy the the journalists robert frank
wrote a terrific book called richard fan
and i've sort of updated it to say well
there's affluent Vil and lower richest
and an upper understand and billionaire
Vil and the appeal to each of those
individuals because they're individuals
might be different let's understand who
they are and what they can do and how we
can build alliances with them so very
much interested in that I say I have a
bunch of chapters about the role of
charity and we could talk about more of
this in discussion but my point of view
I've made point of view is right now
charity is not the philanthropic sector
is not the answer to these issues in
fact philanthropy is becoming more and
more top-heavy we're seeing the creation
of these mega foundations now those that
mirror the growing inequality of wealth
and a decline in donor giving for most
low and middle income people and if you
think about where that's going we're
basically heading toward twenty years
down the road the creation of mega
philanthropic corporations subsidized by
the taxpayer essentially because they
reduce taxable reduced taxation and more
government and local austerity in the
same that's where we're heading
so my point of view is
philanthropy is not a substitute for
taxation adequate and and fully funded
public services and in some cases
philanthropy is compounding the existing
inequalities so it's not the answer it's
certainly part of it but I take that on
let me stop and I think we want to just
have a more open discussion but I want
to just close with one other story which
is what informs my hope or the sense of
possibility that we actually can
transform this current situation I was
talking about these inequality issues in
a suburban Los Angeles Church there were
probably a hundred people there affluent
suburban Church and I had kind of gone
off a little bit like Morris's op-ed
today I would talked about Apple and
Boeing and General Electric and some of
these global corporations that benefited
enormous ly from the infrastructure that
we build together but don't pay a lot of
taxes and there was a nice gentleman at
the end of the talk people were talking
to me in a gentleman was standing there
waiting to sort of for everyone else to
leave and then he came up to me and he
said you know my name is Hank and I have
a question for you but I wanted to tell
you give you a little background he says
first time I'm uh I'm the retired number
three executive at Boeing I thought oh
he said that but he said you know I'm
I'm a bit ashamed about how our our
company behaves and why we don't can pay
more for the infrastructure and roads
and the things that that you know so I'm
a little embarrassed by that but that's
not why I want to talk to you he said my
question the context is I'm retired and
about three years ago I went to Kenya on
a project where I was using my
engineering skills that I haven't used a
long time to help build some water
treatment facilities in rural Kenya and
everyday we showed up there there were
these children that were sort of hanging
out watching us
and they were beautifully colorfully
dressed and and well taken care of
clearly and they would we were like the
best entertainment our little
infrastructure project so I got to know
these children and one day I said show
me where you live and they led him down
a path and across a little creek and
they came to a big white tired wooden
building with a balcony and it said
orphanage
and this guy Hank said you know oh so
this is where you live and out came one
of the adults and he met them and and he
he said you know I went I've sat in the
van going back to my first world hotel
that night and I was awake all night
thinking about these children and then I
got back the next day and their children
were there and I just started thinking
about them and as I left I went back to
the orphanage and I said so I asked the
director is there anything I can do and
he said well we could use more buildings
I mean this is about a third of the
children that need our help so we went
back to suburban Los Angeles and he
started organizing everybody he knew all
his old business colleagues and they
they're going back and forth to Kenya
and he said you know I work for Boeing I
worked in this corporation we didn't
have a lot of discussions we were
focused on a certain project we never
actually in my memory ever talked about
poverty we didn't talk about children in
the global South it wasn't sort of part
of our agenda these are not bad people
it was just that was the framework that
I was in now I'm in an entirely
different framework since those kids
completely cracked open my heart and now
this is my life passion and she said you
know my wife said to me recently Hank
you remind me of the sweet guy that I
fell in love with 45 years ago and my
children have noticed that something has
changed in me and at this point he's
like tears are coming down his eyes and
tears are coming down my eyes and
and he says so my question is and I'm
like oh right he had a question I forgot
he had a question so my question is is
it too late for me to make a difference
and I'm family no absolutely not I mean
you're you're making a huge difference
and getting all these other people
involved because yes since I see the
connections now I now understand poverty
in Los Angeles
it took me going there for my cart to be
cracked open to understand the systemic
causes of poverty and the food system
I'm making all these connections and all
these people I'm pulling in and you know
I said well it seems like cracking
hearts open is the key he says that's
the key I take these guys mostly guys to
Kenya
they're completely ambushed they have no
idea they I take them out of their
environment where they live inside the
mythologies that justify poverty and
inequality and they can't for the life
of them make this doesn't make sense to
them that they're that they're these
realities so and I have to say I have
conversations like that now every other
day with people and what that tells me
is people are waiting for something
bigger and that they are waiting to have
their hearts cracked open and they're
waiting to act on what they know to be
true and so that's to me what the moment
holds for us and one of the things I
realize is people we as humans can
rewire ourselves quite quickly like if
you think about climate change growing
inequality we're talking generations
absolutely not first of all we don't
have generations to fix this and
secondly we are incredibly capable of
changing our context and I'm watching it
happen now all the time so those are the
stories that I feel are key for me to
tell so let me stop there and I would
just and I think Cody has a microphone
but welcome any comments or question
or provocations disagreements I thought
I knew everything but I never heard of
the patriotic millionaires what do they
do yeah well you know over the last
couple years there have been a couple of
networks of I would call them High Net
Worth business leaders or people with
inherited wealth who have been engaged
in public policy Polly and I were part
of starting something called the
responsible wealth I helped start a
network called wealth for the common
good and we recently merged into what's
called the patriotic millionaires
patriotic millionaires now are 250
individuals who are willing to go out
there and talk about fair taxes raising
minimum wage raising wages and reducing
the influence of money in politics all
over the United States I ate or just
earlier Moore's Perl who is actually the
chairman our national leader of the
patriotic millionaires is here and yeah
part of part of what I want people to
know about the patriotic millionaires
because I think it's good news there's
actually some good news there's a lot of
news about greed and selfishness but
there's a lot of very positive news of
people breaking through to their side so
check out the patriotic millionaires and
some of that that work that's going on I
just wondering after we talked about our
lee hak-su book today is there any way
of reaching out to the millionaires who
are on the other side it's an
interesting question
Polly's referring there's a if you if
you're looking to buy another book
tonight other than born on third base
the sociologists are Lee Hoch she'll has
a really interesting book called
strangers in their own land and she
basically spent the last six years
embedded with sort of Tea Party
activists in the south and in her usual
style did a lot of deep listening and
interviewing and sort of trying to
understand that framework and I won't go
over is to the whole thing but what what
I think is that there are what there's a
base of people there again
and where we have a heart problem we
have an empathy problem and what arleigh
tries to say is you know if you want to
dismiss everybody who's in the Tea Party
or supports Donald Trump because they're
deplorable Zoar racists and xenophobia
which is true there are people who have
that but if you want to dismiss them all
then we're missing an opportunity to
understand where these folks are coming
from and her I recommend her book
because it's just sort of a it's a you
could climb over the empathy wall to
understand where people are coming from
I think it's harder with the
millionaires and billionaires who
support the kind of neoliberal tax
anti-tax anti-government agenda because
there's their life experiences different
but I think the opportunities to engage
a lot of other people are part there I
mean I think actually the patriotic
millionaires we have been actually
inviting or engaging with other big
spenders on the political right yes yeah
so they're very involved were we're all
very involved politically just like you
know the Koch brothers on the other side
well probably working to keep Donald
Trump from being elected and whatever
we're yeah are you can move foster
Gamble's in the party be able to me yes
you sang very similar things factor
factor the last 10 years or so and be a
good present too for you to connect with
if you have no ruining that's that's
that's a great idea I mean well you know
it's interesting is a hundred years ago
during the last time we had these
extreme inequalities of wealth you know
there were there were defectors if you
will from the robber barons you know and
there's an interesting history there and
even you know Andrew Carnegie came
around and said we need to tax inherited
wealth we should not be allowing huge
accretions of wealth to build up that
that's fundamentally anti-democratic and
that was you know the movements that got
us out of the first Gilded Age
understood
the concentration of wealth and power
that we're living in is fundamentally
undemocratic and there's a lot of
wealthy people who understand you want
to have a self-governing Society you
want to have a real democracy not an
oligarchy you want to have real equality
of opportunity one of the things I one
of the chapters in my book is about
what's happening to young people in
these inequalities and how the
intergenerational transmission of
advantage is helping miss a kids in the
top 10% take off and and and flourish
they have no student debt they get to do
internships unpaid internships in the
field of study they're prepared for
college and work and all the advantages
whereas all the other kids all the other
young adults are stalled out in the
current economy amount of one of my
message is what where are we going here
you know wealthy families it's maybe
biological people want to help their
kids but we need to de-escalate the
advantage transmission arms race that's
happening where some of these kids are
getting so much advantage and we need to
you know eliminate college debt I mean
the big project that I work with Bill
Gates is dad on is tax well through
inheritance taxation and other
progressive wealth taxation and invest
it in debt-free education you know
that's you know and in Washington State
we were able to get the state wealth tax
to be directed to the education legacy
trust fund we want to replicate that in
other states tax concentrations of
wealth invest it in things that create
real opportunities for everyone else I
think that's the way forward and there's
a number of Gambell family members who
are very much a part of this movement
might you have the DVD holes drive yeah
two hours long as too complicated to go
into now but it would it blew my mind
yeah what you're saying now it's got two
hours worth and yeah he has a hole
anyway it's totally awesome like not
quite quite there in the intergalactic
visitor part but a much more than I'm
Larry yeah yeah
I have a couple of questions one
concerns the CEO pays and thats related
to campaign contributions as you know
you know Wall Street gives a lot of
money to to give to people who are
running for elections and as a result of
that you know they get huge sums of
money as CEO they feel like they're
entitled to that that applies for not
just was not just banks but also to
insurance companies you know like they
get like 25 million 630 million a year
as salary and anyway so that contributes
to income inequality so how do we
overturn these practices of banks and
insurance companies donating significant
sums of money towards the election
process political process and that and
that that way they get lacks regulation
where's that work in their favor and not
yeah I get it so well that so that's
actually this issue of you know removing
the influence of money in politics and
there's a whole bunch of event of you
know work that's going on in that area
actually Morris and a couple of the
patriotic millionaires tomorrow are
going to the moderator of the first
democratic debate with a petition with
35 thousand signatures saying would you
please talk about the state of democracy
and the corruption that's coming about
because of the influence of big money
capturing our democratic system so I
think that's one thing we can do is just
basically say it's unacceptable we have
to break that nexus between money and
influence and our democracy I mean even
Jamie Carter former President Carter
said you know we're becoming an
oligarchy 158 families gave half the
money to the presidential race and the
first half of the cycle I mean where are
we going here so I think that just it's
completely unacceptable on the issue of
compensation there's a lot of
shareholders and this is again where
wealthy people who owned assets and
shares of stock can introduce
resolutions to reduce compensation
ratios and a company raise the floor
lower
gap everybody actually knows that those
are more productive companies where you
don't have these large compensation
spreads they actually have are more
productive and efficient enterprises and
as taxpayers we should not have to
subsidize excessive compensation which
right now that compensation package is a
tax deductible business you know break
and we can we as sit and this is part of
the there's a there's a sort of whole
campaign of a number of reforms to
reform Wall Street and one of them is
eliminate the CEO pay tax break you know
so I think that there are things that
all of us can do to sort of push back on
that system yeah thanks I want to go
back to the breaking open people's
hearts because I think that I believe
that as important as the policy work and
I was remembering a biography I read of
Michael Jordan who star basketball
player and it ended he talked about
basically how his life went smaller as
he became wealthy that he no longer
trusted people to come up to him he
couldn't make new friends but he thought
people were coming after his wealth and
he couldn't trust his old friends
because he thought they were just
hanging on because they would get some
financial benefit and he couldn't go out
shopping anymore because he was a
celebrity celebrity and it's his life
just got smaller and smaller and more
isolated and he was able to reflect on
that and to his biographer so I I just
wonder in your workshop you know as you
interact with whether it's the patriotic
millionaires or the millionaires who
aren't so patriotic you know how much
you're able to you know connect with
them not just on what's happening with
young people in Kenya or in Los Angeles
but around how the heartbreak in their
own lives
and what they're missing because because
of that isolation yeah thank you for
that question you know part of what I
try to tell it you know part of the case
that I make to my brothers and sisters
and the 1% is this isn't just about
helping other people this is about your
own liberation if you will or
transformation that that the current
bubble that people get put in the boxes
that people get put in I think your
description of Michael Jordan is life
becoming smaller or disconnected now
this isn't true for everybody I mean
there are there are people that I know
through the patriotic millionaires
Network who were raised working-class
who are still connected to working-class
communities and friends who somehow sort
of navigate on a daily basis the class
divide but I think as we become more
unequal and pull apart people spend more
and more of their lives in containers
again most people don't live in New York
City so New York is somewhat unique but
even within New York live in containers
of relationships and more and more are
disconnected from communities from place
from each other from others and one of
the things that I write about is a
genuine community is a becomes about
through vulnerability it's through
people needing each other and if you
have gotten to a point in your life
where you no longer need anyone because
you have pretty much monetized all of
your needs you are actually impoverished
when it comes to real connections and
some of us who were raised in in owning
class or wealthy families can you know a
friend of mine he says if I were to
write my family history it would be
called orphans with parents that there
was so little touch and connection in
that family that it was no no all
families are different but there is
something that happens with the social
isolation the being told to be afraid of
the world
that people are going to rip you off you
can't talk to strangers you don't want
to talk to that person isn't in
immediately recognizable to you so my
argument it part of coming home is like
actually rejoining physical community
with people who are not from your own
class and race background build
community break bread form relationships
show up with your vulnerability show up
with your needs there is no real
community without vulnerability
otherwise wealthy people live in
communities of co consumption
what will we consume together food trips
travel culture you know it's only when
somebody has to go to the hospital that
the real connection breaks open and it
that's not how that's not how we're
supposed to be we're supposed to be you
know the motto isn't the person with the
most toys at the end of life wins it's
the person who lives and dies with
surrounded in a community and with
connection to humans and to nature
that's why we're here so well is
disconnecting us and creating those
divisions so on my my argument part of
coming home is you know and I live in a
urban neighborhood in a small thousand
square foot apartment in a two family
house with I know my neighbors I'm you
know in a way this wasn't the life I was
raised to have some of my high school
friends are here they can remember the
house I grew up in in Bloomfield Hills
Michigan you know and there were we had
classmates who were from Detroit and I
remember bringing Shelly Parliament home
to my who's a very amazing dancer she
and I were in this dance group together
and she came to my house and she's like
holy bleep you know do you know how much
you have and I'm so embarrassed and so
ashamed and you know it now I don't have
chosen not to go that way
and life is better one more question
yeah if somebody has an ask a question
here yeah talk to the microphone Aaron
yeah I mean I agree with everything you
said and I think you're you're being a
very good person and trying to do good
things but when you think of the whole
state of the world
what could you envisage as the ideal
outcome if everyone's heart was good
yeah well I think you know I talked
about the trajectory we're on where
we're heading
how that's not in anyone's interest you
know I think we like that arrow at
Cranbrook school aiming straight up in
there if we if we aim it very even if we
change it to a directory little big
changes can happen you know between 1945
and 1955 we as a nation made a
commitment may invested in building
infrastructure and expanding the middle
class primarily for white people almost
entirely for white people but we went
from a homeownership rate in the u.s. of
44 percent to 65 percent in one
generation we we actually completely
changed the trajectory of society we
left people of color behind so there was
a sort of racially discriminatory
element of that but we spent six hundred
billion dollars a year on housing
subsidies and subsidies to help people
build wealth and savings
most of those go to the multi
millionaires we redirect the existing
subsidies and invest that in creating
wealth and opportunity we shift that
trajectory so that's just one tiny
example of 30 or 40 other areas
Institute of wealth tax tax billion
billionaires over a certain percent
invest in a debt free college education
fund for every young person because it's
you can put a price on that and actually
do it and we actually did it after World
War two we actually like reduced
inequality dramatic
we so take those pieces and here's the
other good news we have a political
system that's captured by big money
right now but the base of the US public
is not there the basis wants a much less
inequality opportunity for all taxing
the wealthy raising the minimum wage
invest in all these things that rate so
there's going to be a realignment and I
think the 1% and everybody else working
100% of us organizing together can lead
to a fundamental realignment that in 10
to 20 years this country could look very
very different in the planet could start
to look differently so so anyway thank
you for that question and thank you for
all of you for coming out thank
[Applause]
everybody thank you to check for this
great talk and real quick I'm going to
pull him up to the front so we can make
kind of a queue up for line and after
signing books one small point on Monday
night we have Arlie Hochschild here
woohoo part two of the talk will
continue Monday night so again thank you
check this is great and I'll see
everybody up front come back in here
early if you can
yeah